je sais il n'est pas 20 heures je prends
un peu d' avance mais pourquoi peau dit
on je vous rejoins dans le jardin
nous applaudissons pour manifester notre
admiration et notre enthousiasme pour
encourager sa d'accord mais pourquoi le
fait-on en utilisant les paumes de nos
mains que nous frappons l'une contre
l'autre
selon certaines sources
nos ancêtres du paléolithique devait
déjà s'en lasser se taper dans le dos
les applaudissements serait en quelque
sorte la reproduction de ce geste à
distance au fil du temps la fonction
aussi a évolué les romains ont été les
premiers à utiliser les applaudissements
comme baromètre politique à sondages
avant leurs usages qui se poursuit
d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle selon
certains les applaudissements crée aussi
du lien entre les individus
un peu comme une capsule de des confiné
autre fonction au septième siècle entre
romain d'orient héraclius à l'époque lé
empire romain touche vraiment à sa fin
engage des figurants qui se met à son
armée juste pour applaudir pour
impressionner son ennemi et lui montrer
sa supériorité
bon ça n'a pas très bien marché c'est
beaucoup plus efficace chez certains
animaux dans une publication récente un
chercheur anglais suggère que les
phoques gris bat des membres antérieurs
pour montrer leur supériorité physique
genre poussez vous c'est moi le plus
fort c'est peut-être aussi le sort de
nos applaudissements chaque soir depuis
la mi mars
nous applaudissons pour dire merci mais
aussi parce que nous voulons montrer que
nous pouvons être les plus forts et que
nous avons très envie de lui mettre une
bonne claque à ce satané virus
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celle des jours précédente en cliquant
sur le côté gauche jean publie une
nouvelle chaque jour alors pour être sûr
de ne louper aucune et bien abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche à demain et
surtout n'oubliez pas nous sommes
toujours confiné mais on reste en lien
ce